I couldn't have sex at all in the first
pregnancy really I suppose it my
husband's a big boy Meghan Trainor talks
all things s-e-x and she's not holding
back that's crazy man the singer gets
candid about her sex life on a new
episode of her working on it podcast
with her older brother Ryan and guest
Trisha Paytas saying that sometimes
intercourse with her husband Daryl
Sabara doesn't feel so good I couldn't
have sex at all in the first pregnancy
really what was it my husband's a big
boy and I was like yes she has like I
don't know
oh but also damn no to the point where
I'm like is it all in and he's like just
a tip and I'm like I can't do anymore
you know
I'm like I don't know how should I
stretch
apparently things got so painful when
they were trying to conceive baby number
two that Megan took extra precautions
I'm icing myself and I go there's gotta
be another way Megan reveals that a
doctor diagnosed her with vaginismus
which according to the National Health
Service is the body's automatic reaction
to the fear of some or all types of
vaginal penetration whenever you go
through something difficult and you come
out of it like don't forget to Pat
yourself on the back after that I
thought that every woman walking around
was always in pain during and after sex
I was like Doc are you telling me that I
could have sex and not feel a single bit
of pain oh my God
the mother singer said she's been
turning to different methods to battle
the problem like Transcendental
Meditation but she admits it puts her to
sleep we're just like cute it's gross
like everyone hates us you know when
you're that couple Megan and her hubby
are expecting their second child
together back in January she revealed
the happy pregnancy news on live TV
oh my gosh
[Music]
and earlier this week she revealed the
gender on the Kelly Clarkson show three
[Music]
[Applause]
Megan and Daryl are already parents to
two-year-old son Riley
what has surprised you most about
motherhood
oh how much I cry I don't know like
happy tears every night he falls asleep
in my arms and then I look at him and my
husband and I tear up with happy tears
so I'm like this is all I've ever wanted
well something tells us Megan will
continue to keep it real whether it's
about her sex life my husband's a big
boy or motherhood and we love it
[Music]
thank you